the biden administration
urgently warning this afternoon about
the imminent outbreak of war in europe
president biden will be speaking to
putin tomorrow
the white house saying forcefully that
quote we are in the window of a possible
russian invasion of ukraine which quote
could begin during the olympics that is
before or after february the 20th
that's next friday president biden
warning americans to get out of ukraine
while they still can
what scenarios would you put american
troops to rescue and get americans out
there's not that's a world war when
americans and russians start shooting at
one another i'm hoping
that if in fact he's foolish enough to
go in he's smart enough not to in fact
do anything that would negatively impact
on american citizens american citizens
should leave should leave now we're
dealing with one of the largest armies
in the world this is a very different
situation and things could go crazy
quickly all right with the threat of war
very real i got my dates mixed up there
february 20th is next sunday right
uh with the threat of war very real in
europe the president turning to a
national security rookie with all due
respect vice president kamal harris not
a lot of experience on the international
scene to try to resolve this urgent
crisis despite her failures so far with
issues like our southern border the vice
president will be headed to germany next
week to rally allies against russia uh
this is for real uh judge and i i
i don't know why they're so the the the
warnings are so urgent but they seem to
have real edge they seem to really sound
to me like they are very forceful and
and imminent is the word that comes to
my mind well what's interesting about
this is and disappointing is that he
doesn't imagine a scenario where he's
going to go in and protect americans if
we're in a situation where russia
invades i mean he did it he did it in
afghanistan although he lied initially
he said we're gonna we're gonna protect
the americans we'll we'll take care of
them we'll get them out and and then he
said no we're not gonna get them out now
he's saying ahead of time we're not
going to get americans out that is
disgusting that alone should be enough
you want to talk impeachment that should
be impeachment but the issue of the
ukraine is very interesting because i
spoke to someone today and he said to me
look he said the russians have about 120
000 troops
on the borders they've got about a
hundred thousand in belarus doing
training he says but the russian economy
is so bad that the thought of them
actually invading and actually staying
there doesn't make sense because they
can't afford to keep the troops there
plus since they already have access to
the water and the eastern ukraine that
they're already there they really don't
have to go in there if they go into kiev
the ukrainians are tough fighters and
they're going to give them a real run
for their money so i'm not so sure it's
imminent
the but the problem the the reason it
could be imminent jesse is that just
think of all those tanks parked there
running the engines the whole time think
about uh the soldiers have to eat uh you
they gotta heat they get they get sick i
mean to maintain a force of that size in
the field is enormously expensive he
can't keep them there forever it's it's
use
them
more expensive once they go in with the
supply lines and all the fuel and
everything like that and ukraine is
shooting you know i used to think he
wasn't going in and now i think he might
and just take half of the country and
not even try for kiev but what do i know
i have no idea what he's going to do but
if he does go in he's going to bleed to
death in that country my god i don't
think that's going to go very well for
putin i just imagine what would happen
if trump were president right now and
how the media would be covering this
trump has allowed vlad to gobble up
ukraine in exchange for his help for
beating hillary clinton in the election
donald trump vacationing in in you know
three day weekend at camp david while
americans are left stranded there as
nato crumbles while trump golfs you know
and he sends mike pence so he doesn't
have to go there i mean come on geraldo
oh what about camilla what about
comments
about her i would have said hunter
hunter knows everything about ukraine
but you could look at it this way she's
been begging for a better role you know
what hey there's the big leagues babe
this is high stakes diplomacy you wanted
something big you wanted to go to europe
go for it let's see how it shakes out
other hand you're basically giving her a
really tough thing and she could come
back with russia already invaded ukraine
and germany saying you know what we're
not going to close nordstrom 2 and that
could look even worse you can't go in
judged i i wanted to mention
before to jesse that they can't rescue
americans in ukraine when the russians
are occupied you can't put american
forces and russian forces in the same
yeah because they'll start fighting
it'd be a european war it would be war
but uh
one of the the positive things that the
president has accomplished is
putin is now facing a united nato more
or less nato was shattered remember the
united states was half-assed
participating
there were countries that didn't know
whether joining nato was a good idea
after all uh you know the one thing that
putin has managed is to unite nato again
well we'll see where are the sanctions
then why aren't we being um proactive
rather than reactive ooh if you go in
we're going to lay sanctions on it so
we should have done it weeks ago we
should have take
you know the united kingdom can start
cracking down on the personal assets of
putin and his cronies because most of
them or a lot of them are uh housed in
london or in england number one there's
so much that we could have done why
nordstrom 2 why wait for that that
number one number two
i said this a year ago or over a year
ago on this very show by biden
dismantling our energy economy and
destroying our strength on the world
stage where we were the swing producer
we controlled uh world prices we had the
most excess production capacity we were
the number one energy producer in the
world biden destroyed that and handed
power control and wealth to russia and
iran nations that want to wipe us off
the planet you saw today oil's at 94 a
barrel then he turns around and starts
begging opec to pump more oil in august
so not only did we enrich russia
russia's in a much better economic place
now because oil's at a seven year eight
year high but we also emboldened putin
because weakness is the oxygen of
tyrants
what about on the political front greg
if biden were to announce to degen's
point
we are i made a mistake he didn't have
he doesn't even have to apologize i'm
reopening on an emergency national
emergency basis uh the uh the keystone
pipeline the xl pipeline every other
damn pipeline they shut down every
refinery that they marked
that wasn't built yet they should open
up all land leases they should just say
pump to the sky what would that help
would that save him and us well maybe
but i don't think i i don't know if
that's the issue right now i'm happy
that kamala is going to the ukraine to
explore the root causes of the russian
border problem uh she's probably going
to get the history come back and report
to a nice little book report i also love
the fact that biden has brought us
firmly back into the 1970s we got the
1970s crime rates we've got the 1970s
gas prices now it looks like we're gonna
have a 1970s proxy war with an evil
empire i was looking for if he continues
that he's going to resurrect the manson
family and that's going to be really
interesting where's jim jones he's going
to bring back everything bad about it
but you first my platform shoes yes
you got to ask though how how does this
intel on the ukraine compared to the
intel in afghanistan right we should ask
ourselves that and we brought up nato if
putin doesn't want the ukraine in nato
why do we care this is this is confusing
me reverse history and consider an
independent texas joining the warsaw
pact all right we could say like oh we
do
nato this nato that it's really
important it really isn't that important
what do we get out of this we get
nothing out of this then put it in human
terms yes
uh russia putin is a bully and the
ukraine are the bullied and america is
always on the side of the bullied which
means we should help the ukraine we do
that what should we do oh well if we go
i have to supply arms we have to my
feeling is is that that's not going to
happen so you wouldn't put the 82nd
airborne in hell no
well no what's what good is that for us
what good is that for us yeah well amen
and that we agree hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else